true of details
I'm songs Felicity showed
hope you're in room 0 smoke
systems by
built walls available
we have come
to reclaim old
bio for you my help which house
there was no King under the mountain no
be
not here
every victory this you
group's room
not given hope with a reason
right to it
remember I'm
one of my news
to
I found something
in the government
to fund I'm
my carriage good needed
going
right now
you cannot see beyond its own design
who will know risk this quest
life one book on
his name miss bill
you
home %um each
strip life
on
eighty versus Charlie in the just there
the second trailer for desolation of
Smaug and we finally got to hear
Benedict Cumberbatch speak
as the voice of the Dragon let me know
if you think obviously banniker batch is
done some voice over work before
especially some little stuff I'll try
including the links but I've personally
really enjoyed it
it was really fun to hear his gravelly
voice barely has this distinct voice so
it's easy to understand why Peter
Jackson chose him as opposed to another
traditional voice actor
I also wondered about the giant spiders
in the trailer 2 obviously celeb is a
big character in the Mirkwood mythology
so I'm really interested to see if they
have a voice actor
doing their part there's nothing listed
in IMDB and I couldn't find any
information on it but if any you know if
jobs going to be a movie
be sure to let us know that description
there's also the sexter subplot with
tutorial and Lake alas
obviously pace is playing his father
trained well and he did this week a cock
block in the
trailer I think based on the description
ever character that Peter Jackson is
given she's the Kings guard
and really can't get married and have
children but let me know if you think
what do you think the trailer obviously
they had a few moments lease on the
previous trailer but the big stuff
obviously the spiders
medicare batch and it's a pot with legal
as centauri also I'm really looking
forward to the next row they're calling
this the main trailer
the business going to be one or two more
trailers with some more Benedict
Cumberbatch's
mag be sure to let me know you think
though I'm also going to try and post my
berries video for Game of Thrones Season
four pitchers subscribe to get that
you can click here to watch that video
since I first saw the annotation any
click here to watch my other Hobbit this
lesions popular thank you so much for
watching have passed a smart